the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let's talk about memory today and the
fragile power of memory if memory didn't
work we wouldn't remember anything we
wouldn't learn anything so we know it
has to work reasonably but it has a
number of fragile aspects we'll talk
about where of course we forget things
but on top of that it turns out there's
ways in which our memories get less
accurate and distorted are not actual
records of our experience but rather our
interpretations or our memory of our
memory and we'll talk about experiments
that revealed that so to a large extent
we'll talk about what do we know from
scientific research about why would
remember some of our lives and why we
forget so many other things that we
experience and an aversion of the way
that people sometimes think about it is
in what sense is memory like a camera
that every experience you have is stored
in your mind somewhere we all have the
experience perhaps that something will
remind you of something you haven't
thought about for days weeks or years
right you go oh well there must be all
stored there I just needed the right cue
or the right path to get that memory so
that's one version of memory everything
is in us recorded sometimes we can get
to it sometimes we can't another version
is the way to think about your memory
it's kind of like a punch bowl you put
in some milk and then you put in some
orange juice and swirl it around and
then you put in some coca-cola and swirl
it around and it's not a desirable drink
that you have in your bowl but you can
no more get the specific milk or the
specific orange juice or the specific
coke because they're all mixed together
and it's memory more like that because
the life goes on things get mixed in and
the raw memory is never recoverable from
the mixture of subsequent experiences
thoughts and feelings so we'll bring the
same perspective a little bit bottom-up
memory might be you know really the
video camera if we had it an actual
recording of what we hear what we see
what we experience out there in the
world top-down processes are the mental
things we have in our minds that let us
interpret what's out there
concepts expectations also turns out
you'll see that subsequent experiences
go back and change memories from prior
times and which of these things the
bottom-up original
answer the top-down interpretation grows
over time to constitute your memory so
we can have a very simple model of
memory a flash for a moment will give
you an example of how people test this
of sensory memory very tiny moments only
short-term memory that you can rehearse
in some cases somebody tells you a
number and you can repeat it over and
over again you have that capacity and
then long-term memory things that lasts
for a long time you can define these
things many different ways when we talk
about the brain organization of human
memory we'll say the short-term memory
probably is probably lasts seconds and
everything after that is long-term
memory now of course if you just
experience something you remember it
better if it's a week a month a year
five years from now most likely less
better right so time passes but we think
almost all of that is in the context of
long-term memory capacities of your mind
so here's the kind of experiment I want
really
we'll do a couple of exercises at your
seat but this I'm just gonna give you a
feeling because you have to this would
require millisecond timing to do
correctly but the way they approached
this sensory memory the flash of memory
let just you know capturing for a moment
what's out there it's something like
this so imagine your job is to report
back the letters that you see okay yeah
you're getting a number of them okay all
right so that method would be you just
did what's called a whole report method
tell me everything you saw they did
another approach which is present
letters and then write just just as it
disappeared they would get a tone a high
medium or low tone and that would tell
them which row to report the top row the
middle row or the bottom row depending
on the tone they heard just after the
flash immediately after the flash that
makes sense okay it's gone but the tone
is telling you which one to report and
the striking finding and this was this
if they showed you 12 letters like you
just saw and said tell me everything you
see people could give you about four
letters back maybe you had that
experience about four letters accurately
if they gave you the letters they flash
them then you got the tone for one row
only you've got about three letters
correct now this is interesting the
letters are gone but it's kind of
as if the photograph of your memory is
fading but if you put your attention
somewhere you can still pull it back but
just a little bit of it okay because
here you get four out of twelve here you
get three out of twelve almost the same
because your attention can zoom in on
that fading mental image of what you
just saw so there's much a sense but
attention only selects a little bit to
be remembered okay so that's this very
first moment of memory but you know one
of the more impressive lines of research
is the next moment short-term memory
keeping in mind something in your mind
briefly and one of the most striking
aspects of human short-term memory is is
limited in how much it can hold and
across a tremendous range of materials
words letters shape stones and so on you
can hold approximately seven plus or
minus two chunks of information limited
short-term memory so now I need somebody
who's willing at their chair to do
something you will have to I'm going to
read to you numbers and ask you to
repeat them back but your eyes will need
to be closed and it'll be fairly
challenging
all right thank you very much all right
okay close your eyes and here we go
ready keep your eyes closed into it
repeat after me
six one when I'm done I'm sorry yeah
ready six one nine four repeat ready
ready three seven eight five two repeat
ready ready nine six five two eight
three repeat four two six nine eight
five one repeats very good ready eight
one six three seven two four nine repeat
okay perfect okay your eyes thank you
very much so you did terrific you did
you got four right five right six right
seven right anyway you got a mostly dry
you just reverse one or two okay
seven plus or minus two doesn't matter
how smart you are how advanced you are
there used to be some confusions about
this because they would say kids in
different countries had different limits
okay
and it's a all our country smarter than
your country okay our our educational
system is better than your educational
system it turned out that all of that
got equated around the world if you
counted up the number of syllables that
are in the digits the real unit of
memory here are syllables okay so in
English it's mostly most of the numbers
are one syllable one two three four five
six they're all one syllable seven gets
to right eight is one syllable nines one
syllable in some other languages the
words that go with the digits are two
syllables and the real unit is so
countries that have two syllables they
have lower spans because not because
they were Dumber or heard a worse
education system is because the real
unit is the number of syllables because
you're hearing it it's language okay
sorry okay so around the world it's a
fundamental capacity of the human mind
is that you're limited to this kinds of
stuff so how do we get around that you
why are we not always barely able to do
anything okay with very small amounts of
information so it's just a constraint of
our minds
it's because background prior knowledge
things you know before you have to learn
something has a very powerful effect it
allows you for the information to be
retained in memory but it has a
double-edged sword which is kind of a
theme about today as much as it helps
you remember things it can fool you into
miss remembering things and let me give
you a concrete example so you can have
put you can put chess displays in front
of people who are either beginning chess
players have played for a while or are
masters and this is they're not going to
play they're going to look at it the
pieces will be swept to the side and
then they have to put all the pieces
back out of memory into the same
location where they just saw it they
know that's gonna happen right so it's a
memory test here's the pieces take a
look
the examiner sweeps the pieces to the
side and you put them back as well as
you can you see it it gets swept to the
side and we you reproduce it from memory
what you just saw and here's the
performance of master players and
beginner players in this case so people
who have played a lot of chess and
people play very little chess it's
better to be high the number of correct
pieces and here's there's two kinds of
displays in one kind of displays which
we call the normal displays those are
ones that could really have happened in
a game there were kind of reasonable
configurations of pieces the random
displays are pieces all over the place
in a configuration that you're not
likely to see in a real game of chess
equal number of pieces and look what
happens the best performance our master
players who see a real normal chess
configuration here are the players who
are beginners and look at the worst
performances to chess masters to see a
random setup so what do you guess is
happening yeah
select memorize games and positions so
they're used to seeing those patterns
and when they see a random variation
right says it people who play chess a
lot have a lot of configurations in
their mind background knowledge they use
that background knowledge of what a
chess array means somebody's in trouble
somebody's winning you know something
interesting is happening in this corner
that knowledge helps them escape the
boundaries of 7 plus or minus 2 and they
do a lot better than the beginners for
whom it doesn't mean much it's just a
bunch of stuff out there hard to
remember but what happens here when the
pieces are random the chess masters are
making mistakes because they're putting
the pieces into places they ought to be
rather than the places they perversely
were randomly located ok if you're a
chess player yet you know you don't like
that random board right it doesn't feel
right
and so but they're trying to be accurate
but now they're misplacing their memory
first of what they actually saw with
their mental model of what ought to be
out there ok now the players who are not
so good they don't you don't see much of
a difference between these lines it
doesn't make they don't understand when
it's random they don't understand when
it's organized it's just a bunch of
pieces ok so the double edge of
background knowledge background
knowledge lets you escape the bounds of
limited short-term memory but at a cost
of sometimes substituting in for the
actual experience you had
ok so we'll try this organized and if
people use the word chunking is the way
in which you use your background
knowledge to get big pieces of
information stored that are better than
you'd think from short-term memory
limits so here's a quick one ready oh I
need you know volunteer actually not too
bad
Wow tough volunteer day you're mad at me
about the exam ok thank you ok ready
what were the letters
okay how about these ones all right you
see it same letters it's just that now
you see the chunks and you can map them
onto long-term memory more easily okay
plus I showed it longer okay anybody
else want to try something like this
thank you okay ready here we go ready
Bubba so this is showing that what
letters do you see ready okay now I'm
gonna let your background knowledge
triumph ready all right same letters
right but you can use your back it's the
same letters the others okay you don't
believe me same letters all this this
this one nothing your background
knowledge is useless your knowledge of
words your knowledge of the alphabet
useless same information in a sense same
number of letters same identity of
letters but now your background
knowledge is powerful okay okay I need
somebody else one more volunteer look
thank you ready I'm gonna show you a
sentence this is meant to be hard the
first one don't worry about okay here we
go can you tell me what what they were
that's pretty good okay let me show you
another equal equal number of words
ready go okay well what is it yeah
you would do better okay I know it's
hard to pull these things off well
anyway so 13 words you know people would
do pretty miserably this'll oh you did
very well a lot better at this because
again you can use your background
knowledge of what does the sentence mean
with the orbit syntax all your
background knowledge can be applied
again the power of background knowledge
is immense I can tell you that if you go
work somewhere or just working in a lab
now or if you're working in any worse
you know you might be impressed by
people who are older than you and what
they know and what they can learn and
pick up its background knowledge
background knowledge background
knowledge okay it lets you quickly
understand an idea because you can
interpret it from prior ideas you know
quickly read a paper because you slot it
into prior things you know background
knowledge is incredibly powerful to let
you discover the signal and get a lot of
the specific information
any kind of information out there so Oh
Tyler I left with you this time so right
so we're going to do a quick memory test
you will do it at your own seat here
it's voluntary yeah but I will ask you
to share some a little bit of
information but it's this is for
everybody now not for one person to be
put on the spot so what I'm going to do
is read you a list of words wait till
the end and when I say when I say recall
write down the words from your memory
okay
so I'll wait for a moment you if you get
a pencil or pen or something
okay I see a few people still getting
stuff okay alright ready here comes the
word sir just listen don't write that
would be too easy right
I'll say recall and then right there now
here we go mailbox sardine shotgun
peacock credit detail flicker airline
spinach clarinet recall
okay
here are the answers okay as you look at
this list put your hand up if you got
all ten nine eight seven six five four
three two thank you all right so now
think about this for a moment we said
seven plus or minus two when the words
are presented in a random unorganized
list like this you're pretty much back
to short-term memory limits in many
senses not completely but in many ways
so if you were to tell a person on the
street I mean I have to say two things
about you guys which is certainly true
and complimentary okay you're at your
most of you if you're somewhere between
18 and 25 you're at your peak memory
capacity for the rest of your life you
will never do better it will never do
better for rote learning than you are
right now there's a ton of research that
shows that you will never do better for
rote learning than about 18 to 25 okay
after that is downhill okay you get
other benefits you know salaries go up a
little bit you get Authority that's a
nice one
but rote memory your ear at the top not
only are you the top but you know you
are an incredibly selected academically
achieving group right your MIT
undergraduates right you're incredibly
selected to be the top of the top in
many senses for learning between 18 to
25 as far as MIT can possibly figure
this out right okay
you are our hope for the future right if
you guys can't fix global warming you
know we're in trouble all right so so
you can't get ten words come on we have
big problems to solve right
it's a capacity of the human mind that
we just can't do about more than this
right it's just amazing how limited rote
memory is without other things but it's
a little bit more that we can tell how
many of you got mailbox and sardine fair
number of hands okay how many of you got
spinach and clarinet the last two words
fair number hands how many of you got
credit and detail way fewer hands and
that's what happens on a well-controlled
experiment so this is correct hi is
correct this is what ordered the word
was in the first
you heard say v this was this
experiments 15 words you can see that
people aren't you know here's their
performance two things are noteworthy
people do best for the first couple of
words and sometimes it is the best for
the last couple of words so here are
three delays these delays are zero
seconds what we did you get the list you
immediately write them down and recall
them verbally that's a zero
you know immediate or I wait 10 seconds
and then say now recall or I wait a half
minute and say now recall now for memory
for the first two items what's called a
primacy effect it doesn't matter on all
three conditions those are the best to
remember words on average for most of
the experiment okay
and people think that's a signature of
long-term memory you can get those one
or two words and then you start to get
overwhelmed okay in a long-term memory
here you only get the boost for the last
couple of words if there's zero second
delay there's 10 seconds or 30 seconds
delay no boost so people interpret this
recency effect superior memory for the
last couple of words is a signature of
short-term memory that lasts only
seconds and so when that simple
experiment you can see long-term memory
influences short-term memory influences
and short-term is a very short term it's
just seconds now Epping house is one of
the founders of experimental studies of
memory and he was heroic I mean he he
would just train himself he was nonsense
syllables because he wanted to get rid
of a lot of background stuff rote memory
and he would learn thousands of these
and then test himself and score himself
honestly okay he did it he did the bulk
of the work on himself and he discovered
something that's pretty simple but
that's a has had a huge effect so how
well do you do since you learned
something all in long-term memory if
you're tested immediately 100% of its a
small list and you studied a lot twenty
minutes later an hour later nine hours
later you can see the steep forgetting
up until about 10 hours and then it sort
of hangs in there a forgetting curve a
long-term memory that we you know
immediately afterwards pretty good then
there's a lot of forgetting in 20
minutes and for a day and then things
hang in there this is this or this you
this is a shaped asymptotic curve or
forgetting okay now
here's another mission for you you need
a pencil or just your fingers will work
fine either way you're gonna see a list
of words some will be an upper case some
will be in lower case capital letters
uppercase or it your job as you see them
from top to bottom you just tap your
left hand for each word that's in the
capital letter and your right hand for
each word that's a lowercase letter is
that okay so that's the first risk
capital u tap left the second word is
lowercase u tap right and you just tap
tap tap until you get to the bottom and
then it will go you ready you ready help
me out here you go thank you very much
here we go
excellent all right what were the words
[Laughter]
okay you might be impressed that even
though they were right in front of you
and even though you were looking whether
they were upper and lower case so you
really saw them if you don't think if
you don't bring the relevant background
knowledge to remembering it which is the
meaning of words most of the time our
memory is pretty hideous okay all right
let's try another one now the trick is
gone a little bit so we're gonna do
another you know I'm it's a little bit
of a setup but I can tell you it's
scientifically true okay so now it's the
same idea you can see words but think
about you're gonna read the word if it's
a living thing like a dog tap the left
hand if it's a nonliving thing like a
chair the right hand ready you did
awesome thanks give me go
okay does it feel like you would
remember the words better okay does it
feel like you would what we're okay so
here's what we did the first list is
you've thought about the appearance of
the word in memory that's called shallow
encoding just if it's upper lower case
and typically that leads to pretty poor
memory if you think about the meaning of
the word
we think that's optimizes memory people
call it deep encoding and at least a
better memory and in a wealth control
experiment now here we had a certain
order and you knew there was a trick but
if you have a well controlled experiment
here's what you find if you just think
about the appearance of the word here's
how well you do pretty low even if you
see the word once or twice and if we
look over here at the meaning of the
word you can see one thought about the
meaning of the word is better than two
presentations thinking about the
appearance and two thoughts about the
meaning of the word in your memories
really excellent yeah question confusing
to do one than the other it was a little
bit right yeah
no usually well that if it to the extent
it draws you to think the question is is
the confusion of doing the two different
tasks help you out so roughly speaking
the answer is to the extent it draws
your attention more to the word yes to
the extent you're sitting there going
okay was an upper case or was it living
under noses that's just weirding me out
it's gonna hurt you because your mind is
filled with those thoughts not looking
at what's in front of you is that okay
yeah so but you could do it you know in
these demonstrations it's they're a
little kludgy here's a fun one the
effective context so this is how they
did the experiment you could do it
different ways but this a fun one they
actually went in in the United Kingdom
to the shoreline and that people put
down this old style driving that diving
helmets you know the old big helmets and
you go under the water with the big hose
in front of you to your air source and
they had them learn word lists like you
were looking at word lists on the land
or under water so underwater they're
here okay and then they were tested for
those on the land or in the water and
here's the the core message was you do
better remembering information if you're
tested in the same situation
in which you learned it so what we see
here is if you here's the words learned
underwater you're better if you test it
underwater instead of going on the land
if you learn the word on their land
you're better off if you're test of the
land then if you go underwater the
context in which you learn something
helps you write being studying in the
water underwater and test it underwater
you do better than studying underwater
and going on land or vice versa being in
the same room same time of day all those
things help you a little bit to bring a
memory back because those are parts of
the memory is the context in which you
experience it another approach that
people have taken this is about
organization they'll present a set of
words like this has people to try to
remember them pretty big list you know
but if you take the same words and do
that same words people remember a lot
better because there's a organization
that helps you your background knowledge
of what is a career what does housework
what is a food all contribute to helping
your memory for these items be better um
so let's think about forgetting
something we know something from last
year we forgot it there's at least two
ideas that people have said what's the
core reason we forget things one of them
is like passive well I even used it for
a while yeah yeah it's just not
available anymore because time has
passed not been used not available
that's passive forgetting the other way
to think about why we forget is not that
it's a passive loss of knowledge but
that experience is you have after that
moment when you learn something we'll go
back and write over and muddy and
confuse your memory for the original
event its active interference of
subsequent experience it's not passive
withering other stuff is getting in your
head that's writing over and modifying
the original memory and the original
memory is never there again and one and
people have talked about in two
different directions that you can think
about this one of them is what they call
proactive interference where things from
before mess up you're learning on
something or retroactive interference
you already have the memory and now new
things mess you up
and write over the memory so memory is
threatened what came before the
experience
well what happens after the experience
in the way that it interferes with
accuracy of memory so here's a fun
experiments just two subjects but
there's a lot of other studies that
looked at this as a regional
demonstration where people had to
remember syllables and they Tet they
talked in the syllables just before they
went to sleep or as they woke up in an
in each case they were tested for
example some number of hours later let's
say eight hours later and their idea in
this study and there's one wrinkle also
called mentioned now that we know things
their idea was but when you go to sleep
there's no retroactive interference
because you're not learning anything
else you're not experiencing you're not
talking you're not reading so when you
wake up in the morning nothing has
messed up your memory from when you just
went to sleep it's that make sense if
you study in the morning now you go and
you have your day you go to classes you
talk to people you read things all those
new experiences can go back and mess up
the memory you acquire to start with so
in both cases you get the memory to
start with but in one case you're
sleeping for eight hours it's not messed
up in the other case you're out in the
world lots of new things are happening
there retro actively messing up the
memory and answer let me just do just
googling it and you can see the people
who did who slept after they learned
when they woke up did a lot better than
the people who walked around during the
day and that's thought to be one of than
a huge line of research saying that one
of the reasons that memories become
unavailable to us is not simple a
passive withering but active other
mental experiences that block right over
and change the original memory question
yeah
so now there's a second thing we now
know the question is is there something
good about going to sleep after studying
and the answer is there's a lot of
evidence now in animals and and
increasingly in humans that sleep is a
period that can solve fixes memories
from the prior day and if you if you
don't get the right kind of sleep or
something like that does memories from
the prior day doesn't seem to get as
well fixed into long-term memory so this
is mixing those two issues these people
have two advantages now we think one
advantage they have is they're not
having new experiences during the night
that are messing up the memory they got
okay and they're having this
consolidation period during sleep
people have long study like what's the
use of sleep okay besides making you not
sleepy
and what are the most fascinating things
and there's just more and more evidence
for this is that it's a peer where
because our brain is kind of quiet in
many ways it seems to work a lot on
fixing memories from that day into a
better long-term unit said okay so
there's people have two advantages by
our current understanding
so that's retroactive inference let me
give you an example of proactive
interference and here's how they study
it we won't try out but let me give you
an example they would have you hear
three words like banana peach and Apple
they're all related then they have you
count aloud from 138 backward by sevens
for a few moments okay they say what
were the words and you give what you can
then they give you plum apricot and lime
count backwards by sevens Mel and lemon
room you can see all these are from the
same category and then they switch the
category so we said typically background
knowledge helps but here's the way it
can get weirdly not helpful so here's
the performance of you know healthy
young people doing this so this is
percent correct good as high the first
lists are really good okay occasionally
they forget one of the three words but
look what's happening is they go along
for the second list and the third list
they're getting worse and worse
that's proactive interference the
experience and the first list is messing
you up to learn the new information the
second list and most of the errors
people make our substitutions they go
plum apricot apple okay by the third
list they're going melon lime apple okay
because you see what's happening because
they're related
because they're related now you're
getting confused it's a second if I just
if I heard the word grape recently was
that in the first group I'm not
reporting that one right now is in the
one before that or the one I'm supposed
to report right now the relations among
them mess you up because it's hard to
tell when you heard them and they're all
related and just to convince you that
it's true because you might say well
maybe you're just getting tired you know
like lists and lists and Counting then
they give you a new list and look what
happens if it's fruits still fruits
you're still stuck but if it's another
list like vegetables flowers and meats
or professions very different your
memory zooms right back up because all
the interference you had here about
fruits is no longer relevant for
learning a set of professions and it's
kind of graded right we think of flowers
is more related to fruits kind of and
professions as very unrelated you know
doctor lawyer programmer right the more
unrelated it is the more your memory
goes right back to where it was because
the proactive interference is no longer
happening another thing that researchers
have focused on is you know as we read
things or and and where do we focus on
so here's an example where they read
people's sentences read the issue saw
censor read them and then they tested
them and either for the meaning or for
the style of the sentence now usually
when we read stuff we're focused on the
meaning not the style right I mean style
we might notice it but usually we just
what am I reading what's the point now
if they were warned that they would be
tested if they weren't aren't warned
they read the sentence then you're
tested much better for meaning than for
style because we automatically go for
meaning that's what we go for when we
read by and large when we think about
poetry or something that might be
different but reading typical tests
what's the meaning we strip away almost
the the style we want to get to the
content but people are flex and they're
terrible if they're asked about the
style is a specific organization of the
sentence the word by word organization
but of course if they focus on it they
can do a lot better so this is just
saying we naturally go for gist and
meaning and we try to throw away a lot
of the specific particulars like the way
the sentence was organized the style of
the writing okay so now I'd like to do
demonstration
will work better for some than others
but here we go right so here we go
I'm gonna read you a list of words and
then I'm going to ask you for a couple
different words and ask you if they were
on the list okay here we go ready door
glass pane shade ledge sill house open
curtain frame view breeze sash screen
Sutter
okay was the word glass okay
was the word potato on the list was the
word shade on the list was the word car
on the list was the word window on the
list okay how many people said window
put your hands up you come I heard a lot
of window yes alright now help me out
here okay smart undergraduates like you
at the peak of your memory will about
half the time say yes to window you saw
this demonstration before or you heard
it before
the way they compose these lists is they
ask students to say what's the first
word you think of what that goes with
door the second word and the first word
that goes with door the most common one
they'll put over here we okay that's a
trick word the lure word and then these
are other words that people think kind
of goes with the word door so if you
hear this list and then either you're
tested before did you hear the word
window or see the word window it doesn't
matter whether you see it or hear it
about half a time undergraduates will
say yes I heard it or saw it because
they're getting the gist of the list
this is all about door and window stuff
right so when the word window appears
they have a false or a loser II memory
the rate of false or illusory memories
goes up with age as well when your for
every decade that will pass you'll add a
few more of those okay but even even
undergraduates typically about half the
time they'll falsely recall they heard
the word window again the idea is here's
this double-edged sword
oh we go it's about words that go with
doors and windows so when you get that's
the gist that's the main idea when you
get the word window you falsely believe
that you saw it or heard it so that's
the way that people try in the
laboratory to 2fort to create false
memories that are experimentally
testable we'll talk about real-life
words just in a moment
so we said you know all these things
make it feel like memories more the
punchbowl metaphor than the camera right
because it's all switched together the
proactive stuff the interpretation the
retroactive changes that are created in
memory are all altering the memory based
on the interpretation or based on
subsequent experience so let me stop for
one moment to tell you okay so memories
shaky wouldn't it be cool to have truly
photographic memory I mean that would be
awesome as a student right wouldn't be
bad in life there's only been one well
described case of a person who seems to
have truly photographic memory you hear
various stories most of the people who
you know are things like memory
performers or there's memory Olympics
and things like that they train the heck
out of themselves to use different
methods that can enhance your memory and
they can do amazing things but it's all
hard work okay it's all hard work as far
as we understand it but here's a guy who
was different studied by the RIA and a
psychologist in Russia about a hundred
years ago so this is a guy who was a
reporter at a newspaper and he would go
out and come back and you know type up
the report of what he had seen at some
event for the newspaper and the editor
noticed that this guy never took notes
okay he came back and he just started
typing and the editor said you got to
take notes because you won't know
exactly what happened who said what
exactly you know you'll make mistakes
like I said no I'm always perfect better
said okay you know I'm we're gonna teach
you a lesson about this there's just to
show you and he said oh he he got some
material and he said everybody come
around he's gonna Barris the guy right
I'm gonna read you something you tell me
every word I said
he read him some you know some gibberish
and the guy repeated every word
perfectly this guy truly had
photographic memory and kind of
interestingly when they said wow you a
photographic memory he didn't go yes and
awesome and I'm a superhero right he
said doesn't everybody all right he
didn't he was not he was not aware that
most of us don't remember every single
thing that we study easily and for the
rest of our lives so he would be
presented you know
rows of digits like these studied them
for three minutes and he could recall
them
days weeks and months later perfectly
you could you know okay
truly this is almost the only case we
have well described and well analyzed so
it's really rare he would say when he
would have to think back of a particular
list Oh tell me the one from you know
last year tell me alone from two years
ago
he would have to think where he was and
reinstate you know that in his mind's
eye he would see the room or hear the
voice of the person reading it to him
but you know 50 even 15 years later a
perfect memory for a list like this
wouldn't you like to have that you know
right now I wouldn't mind it either okay
he also was synesthetic that is when he
had things in one modality a triggered
perception like experiences in another
modality he could change his resting
pulse from seventy to a hundred he could
change his temperature by two degrees by
force of Wilson he's an unusual person
okay okay I mean yeah we would we would
love to discover another person like
this on the place of the planet we have
not seen another one well
well-documented probably there is but
you know there sitting somewhere in some
village remembering everything perfectly
going I thought you all remembered
everything perfectly so you could think
wow that's awesome nice superpower to
have is it but he was not a happy person
this is kind of interesting question
because he complained that when somebody
spoke to him like a family member what
would happen was he would be flooded by
a word with some memory for some list or
some event last week last month or ten
years ago okay his family members said
they they you're not listening to me
yeah because every word or thing you
know
triggered back brought back a flood of
memory
he got so miserable that things in his
environment would trigger perfect floods
of memory into his mind and this is
truly like a novel that he would at one
point in order to get rid of memories
and this did not work he wrote them down
on a piece of paper and threw them into
a fire thinking somehow that would work
okay it didn't work her so this is one
of these you know Twilight Zone oh Henry
depending you know kinds of stories or a
where he think it's awesome to have
photographic like memory but in fact it
seems to have blocked in many ways his
development as a person he became once
he realized he was so
such a rare memory became a professional
memory performer and then all kinds of
jobs and finally retreated into a
countryside kind of unhappy treating
people with herbs with his wife and son
so he did not have a happy office in
life I don't know if in this world he
would do better because you could get on
TV shows and become a celebrity or
something if you could do this right but
I says so what's the problem with
photographic like memory do you think
why is it that we kind of wish we had it
at certain moments but what's a drawback
well the drawback seems to be imagine if
you had in your head a photograph of
everything you would have so much stuff
okay that you wouldn't be analyzing it
for the basic point of what it's about
so we just said the risk of analysing
things for their basic point their basic
gist is that we want to get the bottom
message and we give up a lot of the
particulars it's not like a photograph
you know it's like a very small abstract
or a deep note about a photograph that's
in your mind but that's a very powerful
way to approach the world because in all
your background knowledge is instantly
available to help you interpret what's
going on because you're using lots of
connections and very few particulars
okay too many particulars are all
burdensome is probably having too many
generalities let me talk them in about
flashbulb memories so this is a kind of
funny thing we might have you might have
the experience in your own life of very
salient moments big moments in your life
with your family other things you're
doing in your life or you say I'll never
forget this moment because just
everything is so vivid for me what
people call flashbulb in the old days
with Flash clothes so you know we can
never know how accurate your flashbulb
memory is right you got never forget
when I got into MIT the moment cuz I was
wearing my lucky socks and it was sunny
outside and you might be right or you
might be wrong okay so there's a
slightly gruesome research enterprise
which takes public events that are very
emotional for people so this some of
them will be very historical for you
some are in your lifetime john f
kennedy's assassination the Challenger
blowing up as a high school teacher was
you know going up to be the first high
school teacher to do that the OJ Simpson
verdict
you guys are too how old were you even
alive for the oceanographer sir I can
tell you that got an unbelievable amount
of interest because I'm from Buffalo
that's where Jay Simpson played football
so I had a particularly you know it was
like everything you wanted in a TV show
I mean some that tragically two people
died because OJ seems a super famous
football player that huge debates about
whether he had murdered his wife and and
another person in a house and there was
an exact moment when they said get
everybody get on your TVs you know here
comes a verdict okay or the 9/11 attack
yeah so here's this funny research
business what people do is they go and
as soon as these horrible things happen
they ask people to write down where were
you what were you doing how did you
learn about it what were your feelings
what were the feelings and people around
you and what do you do in the next hour
okay
they can't you can't be prepared for
this other than wait for something
horrible everybody says I'll never
forget where I was when 9/11 happened or
things like that people feel that way
and they certainly remember that day
more in some sense than a typical quiet
day okay but here's what they do if they
test them on their own answers you know
so that you gave the information just a
little bit after presumably it's roughly
correct if you're tested a year later
yes you remember that day better than
other days that's but it's full of
errors it's full of errors and people
are way overconfident they say I know
where I was and a year later and you
know I know I was with my friends and
you say but what a year ago you wrote
down you were by yourself
oops but I'm pretty sure I was wearing
you know my raincoat and you go whoops
you wrote down you know you were wearing
a sweater
oops okay so your memories way higher
but it's full of inaccuracies even
though people are sure it's not they're
sure that's not inaccurate okay and
that's that's the way so the next
horrible public event that happens
there'll be a bunch of memory
researchers running around and my teams
were saying where were you what were you
doing what were you feeling because we
need that to be able to verify whether
your memory for emotionally intense
experience is accurate or not and how
long it lasts okay so a couple
experiments in the video so here's I
witness testimony there's
be more dramatic in court right and the
TV shows are in real life if you have to
be around these things where the person
says you know who was the person who
murdered your neighbor and you go that's
the moment that's the man right Wow okay
okay so how accurate is eye witness
testimony I mean of course it has to be
somewhat accurate we're not living in a
crazy world where people are randomly
imagining things right how accurate is
it really because so here's the kind of
an experiment they did this is work from
Elizabeth Loftus as a leader in this
area she would have people just see
slides this is before computers
basically where sports car would come to
an intersection would turn and would hit
a pedestrian in the slides so it's not
the drama of really seeing it you know
it's a staged thing and it would be
either a yield sign or a stop sign just
before the car turns that you would
clearly see and let's pretend you were
in a condition where you saw the yield
sign then afterwards they would say did
another kept car pass the red Datsun
while it was stopped at the yield sign
that's consistent the word yield or did
another car pass the Datsun while it was
stopped at the stop sign seen you
slipped in the word stopped right or in
neutral you don't say anything and now
you say which slide did you see okay you
show them the actual slide with a stop
sign or a yield sign you saw the yield
line but here's what happens if you saw
the yield sign in you and you are shown
this yield sign you do pretty well
consistent but look what happens if you
saw the yield sign you've got the
question did you see a stop sign and now
you're tested which what did you
actually see you're pretty much wrong
you're pretty much saying I saw a stop
sign
that's retroactive interference you saw
the yield sign you were asked about a
stop sign and now you believe you saw a
stop sign that's why it's so important
how police or other people interrogate
witnesses right because if they saw if
they slip in certain words people have a
hard time going back to the original
memory Delvin memory that's a mixture of
the original experience and the
questions asked about that experience so
people say oh that's just a laboratory
experimented in real life that wouldn't
happen so they did this experiment Jim a
graduate student reminded his younger
brother Chris that they lost Chris in
all when Chris was five and then and an
older tallish man brought him back so
that would be a pretty traumatic thing
for a five-year-old to be lost in them
all and have an old man take you back
right okay all right certainly for the
parents were going where's the kid
where's the kid so two days later Chris
says the younger kid yeah yeah I was
with you guys for a second and and I
went over to look at the toy store the
KB's store and then we got lost I was
looking around I thought oh I'm in
trouble now you know and then I thought
I was never gonna see my family again I
was really scared you know and this old
man I think he was wearing a blue
flannel came up to me was kind of old he
was kind of bald he had a ringer here
Chris Chris was never lost
he was never this Jim the graduate
student mean to his younger brother
before good science reasons told him
this slight story he didn't to give him
any of these details
he just said remember when you were at
five years old he got lost in the mall
and the old tall man brought you back
but what's happening is you know our
memories of when we're kids are pretty
vague you know Chris is sort of mixing
in some real things that happened and
the story and he's fabricating you know
four-note he's not trying to get away
with anything
he's just creating this false memory so
um and he said I don't know we want even
more lifelike than that so here's the
experiment they did they had 120
students see an ad for Bugs Bunny at
Disneyland to a value at the ad so you
brought into a room and say we want to
market test whether this is a good ad
for Disneyland and then they said you
know and when then and these are and
then and all these people had been to
Disneyland some years ago with kids in
real life okay then they said you know
by the way we're thinking about bugs
bunny when you were there did you meet
him did you shake his hand now what's
the big trick about bugs money
Disneyland I saw some smiles right away
he's Bugs Bunny is one of the few
cartoon characters that many kids know
that's not a Disney character okay and
by law cannot be found at Disneyland or
Disney World but one out of three
college students remembered seeing Bugs
Bunny at Disney World or Disneyland when
they were a kid after they had just seen
some promotional material showing Bugs
Bunny you know shaking hands right they
sort of forgot
you know because they had been there
they don't remember stuff okay Bugs
Bunny sure okay alright alright so again
how potent is this way that we mix up
new information with the original
experience that we can't tell apart the
original memory from the mixed-up new
relevant information I mean this would
not have worked of course if they show
you King Kong right you've got there's
no way I saw King Kong all right it has
to be slightly credible yield stop yeah
but it but it's just but it's a pretty
big difference in some cases so here's
one example in real life this is a real
case in a dark October night a woman
hitchhiker picks up on Pacific Highway
south of Seattle a hitchhiker turns into
an isolated rope the man brutally rapes
her and leaves her by the side of the
road 24 hours later she looks in an
array of photos and she picks out a man
who was convicted because she says
that's the man who brutally raped me a
few months later and another man is
arrested for a series of rapes she sees
his picture in the newspaper and she
realizes oops sadly this is the man who
attacked and raped me okay he's released
from jail because he's by then he's lost
his money his job his fiancee his
reputation he since four years pursuing
a law suit he dies 11 days prior to the
trial 10 months later his estate gets
2.8 million because the police weren't
very careful how they did the photo
lineup it turns out if you look at the
photo lineup his was the slightly
outlier picture of the six pictures okay
so the woman went for that guy so when
she's accusing in court she's not trying
to lie
what's she mixing up her memory for the
photo array versus her memory for the
original event those two have gotten
blended in the punchbowl of her memory
that make sense perfectly with good
intention and and you know there's
80,000 trials of your estimate that rely
on eyewitness testimony and many many of
those are mistaken it's just human
nature to mistake them especially
because trials are not boom one minute
later there lots of discussion lots of
this you know interviews with policemen
or prosecutors or lawyers lots of things
happen from the original crime moment
until that moment in court every
discussion and thought and feeling you
have from the original experience blends
in with the original experience and it
can be hard to
pulled us apart here's another sort of
weird example a woman at home in
Australia she's brutally raped in her
home she identifies Donald Thompson I
can see why this is a bit ironic and
weird story a renowned Australian
psychologist who studies eyewitness
memory problems okay it turns out he was
on television at the moment that she was
being raped and obviously she's in a
very disturbed difficult moment and so
she conflates
the face on the TV with the face of the
actual horrible perpetrator okay so he
has a good alibi he's on TV somewhere
okay but you know in a perfectly good
way I mean she's trying to be correct
these things get jumbled together so
you're gonna see in one minute a film of
a Susan Mason so here this is an amazing
story eight-year-old girl will start
you'll see the film filing Franklin but
she Susan a sense an eight-year-old girl
who was missing and found murdered in
October 31 1969 20 20 years later
Eileen Franklin you'll see her remembers
that her remembers that her father
murder Susan Ison testifies against him
when he's found guilty and goes to jail
he's been subsequently released because
she says I was with him when he murdered
my little friend but she doesn't
remember it continuously she remembers
it because a therapist has had her think
about her past and alissa and what she
feels like it was a repressed memory
comes back so we're gonna show time to
figure a movie about this topic it's
your next paper topic what's the status
of memory so this lets separate two
things because it's really important
cases where women or men more often
women remember being abused sexually
abused you know they remembered all the
way through they may not like to think
about it but they remember it all the
way through that's that's not what we're
talking about now but we're talking
about our the the rarer cases where a
man or a woman says I haven't thought
about this I feel like I've repressed
this for 20 or 30 or 40 years and now
more often than not because of some men
working with maybe a psychologist or a
clinical psychologist to help me with
problems I have more you know I would
cover my repressed memory
and it's a brutal thing because you can
imagine on the one end you have a say a
young woman accusing her father or uncle
or the father would say of doing
something that we think is a you know
terrible which is sexually abusing her
the biggest you know failure of trust
you can have in a father the biggest vow
you know a huge violation said he's
horrible if she's right but if her
memories inaccurate
what's more horrible than an innocent
man being accused by his own daughter of
sexually abusing her because her
memories incorrect so I'll show you two
films briefly and then we'll yeah
so the father went to jail so here's
here's the lawyers who were defending
the father who wanted to tell the jurors
the following thing which is you know in
every account you read is accurate that
when that everything that she described
about the death of that girl says in
nice and every detail she described was
in the newspaper accounts at the time
and that no detail that she provided was
you know verifiable and different that
newspapers had reported at the time so
so you know one of the things that
people like to do investigators is have
the person knows something that wasn't
publicly released and everything that
she spoke about in regards to the little
girl's murder Susan Nason's was publicly
available information that had been on
television or in newspapers and the
judge originally ruled that the jurors
could not be told that and then later on
they retried the father the jurors were
killed dead and the father was let go
from jail so there was this huge
pendulum swing because originally as
these repressed memory cases were
brought up peoples who well why would
the woman lie about such a horrible
thing it's so horrible
of course she must be telling the truth
and of course the father must be lying
to protect himself but now especially in
the context of repressed memories again
very different than continuing memories
the ones that were recovered after
decades there's a suspicion that some of
them might be inaccurate and that some
some psychologist working with some
patients might be having patients think
about possible sources of their
difficulty and these memories get
falsely constructed and the hard part in
the part that you write your paper about
is knowing which is which right because
it's heart-rending right you know it's
heart-rending to have a woman who was
abused be not believed
it's heart-rending for a father who was
not an abuser to be accused of being an
abuser and it's incredibly hard to have
direct evidence about who's telling the
truth and is not in these kinds of cases
that are so far from when the crime
occurred and you know what might have
occurred and you know where there's a
such a long period of non discussion
about it because it's been repressed
decades so you look at that it's a big
task it takes you into course in case
you into clinical complexities of people
you